- It's one thing to be seen,
it's another thing to be seen for what?
Are you being seen
because you know how to kick
a football past a goalie?
Are you being seen because
you're wildly attractive?
Are you being seen because you're funny?
Are you being see because you stole money
and it looks like you've made money?
Like what are you being seen for?
I wanna be seen more than
anybody in the world,
why I'm being seen is
what I'm most proud of.
(cheering)
You got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(hip hop music)
YouTube what's up?
So, so grateful that you clicked
and you're about to watch
a new YouTube video.
But before you do, 212-931-5731,
that is my texting community platform.
I'm doing a lot of one-on-one
in engagement in there,
and also, access opportunity first looks
in that environment.
212-931-5731, join it now,
and now, to the video you've
been wanting to watch.
- GaryVee.
- Yes, sir?
- Gennady Vaynerchuk.
- Very good, you got it.
- Who the fuck are you?
Nuh-uh, wait, before.
I read a very cool stat that
said that people who swear
are usually much more honest people.
I swear, you swear way more than me,
but I want you to be as
honest as you want, feel free.
So I'll start with, who are you?
- I'm a very grateful human
and that gratitude drives
a lot of functions of my life.
The way I build businesses,
the reason that I'm even
doing this interview,
aka, people know who I am.
At its core I'm a deeply
grateful individual who,
you know, for context was an
immigrant from the Soviet Union
who went to the US and
like many immigrants
in many parts of the world
had the luxury of the
adversity of that situation
become foundational which also led to
a complete lack of entitlement
which leads to humility
but deep drive and conviction.
Well parented, very well
parented, and deeply ambitious,
you know, deeply
ambitious for legacy first
and that's who I think I am.
- You hit so many things
I want to talk about
but the first one is your childhood.
How do you, I know you left Belarus,
I know at one point you had
eight people in the studio.
How did that shape you?
- I think it shaped me a lot, you know,
I think that not having
a lot at a young age
is a very big advantage.
You know, it's very hard to be
hungry when you've been fed.
And so I think it shaped
me in a lot of ways,
A, I'm extremely close to
my mother, like very close.
B, you know, not only did
we not grow up with a lot
but on top of not growing up with a lot,
my mom is deeply cheap.
So even when we--
- I can relate,
there are some things in
my life that are the same.
- It's crazy even we
got to like middle-class
we still lived in like, you
know, it's fun to think about
as I've gotten more notoriety
and as I've challenged myself
to bring more value to people
I've had to think a lot
more about what's worked
and then you just start
thinking and I'm like,
wait a minute, you know,
things that I never thought,
feeling like, wait a minute.
After a while we were not that poor
but we still didn't buy anything,
oh crap, my mom's cheap.
- You know, I think it's a mentality.
- It is, well my mother,
my mother's dad, my
grandfather kind of, you know,
in communism you're not
allowed to really own anything
but it was all black market
and he kind of, you know,
clearly I've got my, both my grandfather's
had a lot of entrepreneurial DNA
so it makes a lot of sense of who I am.
She kind of was like pretty well-off,
which by the way in Belarus in
the 1950s and 60s was ghetto
but she was the ghetto
queen of the ghettos
and then my grandfather
went to jail for 10 years
in communist Russia
and she lost everything
and I think that has
always stuck with her.
Her having a little something in context
and her losing that.
We talked about it last week,
like, you know, I'm
trying to get my parents,
I'm encouraging them,
they're thinking about
buying a home in Miami to go down,
you know, they're getting older,
they're in their mid
60s, they're starting to,
I want them to enjoy this next decade
and she's a cheap girl from
the old country, she really is.
- I mean, it's very
interesting because my mom
went through shit in her life
and even when she became secure
she always feels that it's not secure yet
and it's not stable, I need to
have this much in my account
to feel like I'm okay.
- And for me it's a little
different but the same.
I don't have a number I need
to have but I save money.
Which is like something
nobody talks about anymore.
Everyone's like, how do I raise money?
Nobody talks about saving money, you know.
- So your relationship with
your parents you think is good?
- Yes.
- Solid?
- More than solid.
- That's great.
- I would argue that I fear
the death of my parents
at the same level that I
fear the death of my children
which I think is unnatural
which speaks to the relationship
I think I have with my parents.
- Moving, I know you're not a
fan of the educational system.
- I'm not.
- I'm not too but unfortunately
it's a very intrinsic part
of the world where we're in, right?
So we can criticize it
so much, me and you,
'cause I'm the same and I talked about it.
but what do you think is really,
maybe quick changes that we
can do to at least start being
in the right path of education?
- I think we have to understand
that every single human is different
and if we don't reverse engineer
what they're good or bad at
and they have to go
through one singular system
it's inconceivable that we're
doing anything good for them.
Miraculously 33% of those
kids, 18, 29, 54, 71
will get what they want.
I just think that it's
unfortunate to force somebody
from 6 to 18 or 22 to go through a system
that brings them no value
and prepares them for nothing
that happens in real life.
How are we still in 2020 in a world
where we do not educate
children on how to manage money?
Like?
- It's not even there.
- Not a kid is being taught
about how to manage money,
every kid is being
talked about outer space.
Who gives a shit about outer space?
I don't care about Saturn.
People don't know how to pay their taxes.
It's a complete, A, it
doesn't work for everybody
and everyone has to do it, that's bad.
B, looking at the room here
and definitely the
people behind the camera,
anybody who now lives life post-school
realizes there's an
enormous amount about life
that we were not prepared for
in any shape or form, why?
- One size fits all.
- One size fits all,
can't work for anything, two,
even what's taught in there
is missing core things.
Why don't we teach self-esteem?
Why don't we teach money management?
why don't we teach--
- Mental health,
let's talk about that.
- Why don't we teach
anything that's valuable?
Everything that's taught is
stuff that people memorize.
Why should I memorize
something I'll give you,
where's my phone, I got
the answer on my phone.
It's great, the whole system
is fundamentally broken.
- I think that what I find bizarre
is that when we are born literally
what they talk about is how
unique your fingerprint is,
how unique is a person and
how special you are, right.
But then all the big systems
are one-size-fits-all.
Education, all of you have
to have a bachelor's degree.
Yeah, but I don't want to study.
You have to pass biology.
I don't like biology, no, you have to!
But you said I'm special, you
said I'm unique I don't want.
No, you have to.
So suddenly if you don't even have a CV
who looks at you today,
very few corporations.
- Who wants to work for a corporation?
- But you see what I mean?
- But by the way, the best
corporations in the world
are not looking at CVs anymore.
College req, Google, Facebook,
these are not college required companies.
VaynerMedia proudly does not,
- That took so long, Gary.
- Yeah, but listen, a lot
of things take so long.
Like we, it took us so long
to demonize beating your wife.
It took us in America in
1975, in America in 1975
half the states it was
legal to rape your own wife.
It takes so long for everything.
We had concentration camps
that murdered millions
of Jews 70 years ago,
we do a lot of things that are stupid.
People are very funny, they're the best
but we have tons of stupid things
and the modern education
system in an internet world
makes no sense.
- One of the lectures I heard
you said that 99% of the entrepreneurs
that were attending would fail.
And I'm like, shit, that's refreshing
because I hear all the
fluff on the other side,
all of these life coaches
sending so many words,
giving that 24-hour boost of
morale which then crashes.
And I'm like okay at
least this guy is real.
The question I have which is also related
to what you just said,
in the time when we have the internet,
me and you when, I'm 38
now, I don't know how old--
- 44.
- We didn't have internet
in the beginning.
Today they have every tool,
every research to not fail,
why do you think so many
entrepreneurs still fail?
- 'Cause it's hard.
It's hard, this is,
entrepreneurship got cool.
Look at you and I.
Look at you and I right now
dressed and acting at 38 and 44
when we were 6 and 7
years old people at 38
did not wear the Travie Scott's, Nikes,
you know, like it's a different culture.
But it's hard, it's hard, number two,
entrepreneurship got cool.
And that's the biggest issue right now.
- It's trending.
- It's trending, people like,
you know how it's crazy, like,
I'm the coolest I've ever been at 44
because entrepreneurship got cool
and now everybody wants to
be one, just like a rapper,
just like an athlete, it's that cool.
- That's dangerous.
- It is.
- Because first of all every guy
wants to do it because
it helps him get girls.
90% of them should not
be entrepreneurship.
Entrepreneurship is super lonely.
It's anxiety filled.
I was telling DRock yesterday
I hate being on this part of the world
because when we go to sleep
there's still action going on in New York
and New York is where
most of my headaches are.
- And I can't attend to it.
- And I can't attend to it
so I go to sleep not as comfortably.
It's lonely, right?
- Yeah, I hear that.
I mean, I wake up at 3 a.m., write a note
so I just don't forget
and then, it's quite--
- It's not, and right
now people raise capital
so they can make pretend they're winning.
When you raise capital you can disguise.
- Success.
- Correct.
So I'm talking about it
not because I wanna say,
I'm an entrepreneur and you're not.
I'm saying it because I
know what happens next.
What happens next is
the money stops flowing
'cause there's a global economic slowdown.
And I do believe that 90%,
95% of the people that we know
that have startups will fail
because they didn't build a business,
they were building a deck
to raise more capital.
- Yeah, they're in for a
completely different reason.
- Completely different,
they're not in it for the game.
They're in it for what
how it makes them look
and the potential of money.
- That's very dangerous, like,
this is what I tell a lot
of students in university,
I'm like, you don't see
somebody who has a cafeteria
making money like, oh, he's making money,
I should open a cafeteria.
And that's what you see, you see
cafeteria, cafeteria, cafeteria,
dry cleaner, dry cleaner,
and like, just because he
made money you shouldn't,
why are you doing it?
So you have to have passion
but you have to have the skill for it.
Do something you're passionate of
but you're actually good at.
- Or if you have the passion
and your skill is okay
settle into knowing that
you're only gonna make 130,000.
- Accept that.
- Aim for happiness,
be self-aware, I'm not
the best fashion designer
but I love it so much that I know
I'm not gonna make five million a year
but I love it so much, right,
nobody's talking about that.
- It's a winner's mind.
- I mean, like, look, this is real for me.
I want to make the $130,000 take home
fashion designer happy.
The problem is right now
every fashion designer
wants to become Off-White.
They are like if it's not a,
there are kids running around
thinking that if they don't
build a billion dollar company
it's not a big company.
We've completely lost sense of reality.
It's completely broken.
- One thing to complement
what we're saying is
I read, I've done a bit of
research, thanks to Nikki,
that you at one point were posting,
I think a video every day on
YouTube for years, correct?
- Yes.
- Okay,
and this I think is what
people don't realize is
the hard work, the focus, the
consistency, and the quality.
- Nikki, what you weren't able to research
was from 2007-2011 I replied
to every single email and Tweet I got
until four in the morning.
Nobody knew who I was so I
would go into Twitter search,
search wine terms and
jump into conversations
that people would tweet,
having this pinot noir,
and I would reply, they didn't know me.
And I would reply, that's a good one,
did you try the year before?
And slowly but surely four
hours and hours and hours
for years and years and
years I built a foundation
that years and years and years later
started the creation
of what people see now.
And meanwhile people
start a TikTok account,
post five times, don't go viral,
and they're like, this sucks.
- But that's the issue.
- I know what the issues is.
- We're in a drive through
convenient no waiting,
so if people are in relationships
which we briefly talked about,
as soon as they don't like
it, okay, bye, fuck it.
They want to order food to go too,
they want to date, they go on Tinder.
It's so quick gratification
that I'm not even wired
to just fucking wait.
Or I go the gym, they go three times
and I don't have a six pack.
You need need to go for three months,
you need to eat better.
But they don't want,
they'll go do liposuction.
And it's scary that nobody giving that,
what I was asking you about,
the consistency of effort.
- You're preaching.
The lost art of patience and foundational.
And this has a lot to do with parenting.
Our parent's generation around
the world where they could,
when they, they borrowed
money from parents.
Our parents borrowed
money from grandparents
and paid them back if they wanted a house
or start a business.
Now kids think their parents
should just give them money.
If you're 22 years old
or older in the world
and your parents are giving you money
you're in deep trouble.
- Why though?
- Because you have been
told by your parents
and you've told yourself
that you were incapable
of standing on your own two feet.
- Correct.
- Which immediately leads to insecurity
which leads to very bad behavior, the end.
And then when I say
this, and this is maybe
the fifth or sixth time
I've said this publicly,
I'll get a bunch of emails
saying you don't know me,
I have two children from
a bad man who left me,
I'm like, live in a worse house.
I'm like why do am I looking at your,
if your situation's so horrible
and you need to fake your appearance
why did I just click
your Instagram account
and you have a Prada bag?
We've become so materialistic
that people want all these
things but they want them.
The question is why do they want them?
They want them because we're
communicating to the world.
Every one of us right now is
wearing what we're wearing,
our haircuts, everything, communication,
we're positioning ourselves to the world.
I really, really think
there's a lot of important conversations
that are not being had.
I'm trying to throw them
out there and I enjoy,
I remember you know meeting
with you like a year ago,
like, I like when people see what I'm,
and my hope is that if I have the courage
to say stuff that people
aren't talking about
then others will start doing it.
Like these are important,
this is an important video.
If one kid or grown-up
watches this on YouTube
and changes their behavior,
that's intense legacy.
- By the way, it's a passion project,
there's no sponsors,
I even remove the ads.
- I believe you.
- I want to do content for
the sake of good content
because it's lacking,
we need thousands of us.
- Thousands.
And eventually it becomes the culture.
This is the first year that I've seen kids
and cool kids post on their Instagram
things like gratitude
and empathy and kindness
and I'm like, I'm making
an impact, you know.
- With all the profit there
is, the demand, the power,
it's not easy to sustain
relationships today.
You we're talking about
other people that quit,
how do you survive, I don't
want even use the word survive
because I think it has
a negative connotation,
how do you sustain a healthy relationship
with all that attention?
- Every relationship,
whether it's your spouse,
your boyfriend, girlfriend,
your children, your parents,
your business partners, your siblings.
Every relationship is 100%
predicated on communication.
- And that's your secret.
- And that's it.
And when it works for me it
works 'cause of communication
and when it doesn't work for me
it's because of break
down to communication.
And that's it, that's for me
and that's for every other
single person on Earth.
It's kind of like everything
else we talk about,
I think one of the things
that's been obvious to me
in our limited interactions
with each other
is I don't think we overthink things.
You made a great point
about plastic surgery,
I think about that a lot, I really do.
When I talk about business
or how simple I just answered
the relationship question,
all of this is wildly simple.
People just don't want to do it.
You want your body to look better?
Eat better and go to the gym, that's it.
- Very simple.
- That's it.
Every course, every book,
every conference, every video
is just extra layers of
fat on a very simple thing.
You want to build a business,
here's how you do it.
Make something that people want,
make it always about the customer,
make it always about your
employees, be patient,
be disciplined, rinse and
repeat, rinse and, you know,
these things can be wildly simple.
The problem is we complicate them.
More importantly, the
things that are simple
are actually hard, it's hard.
- To do simply, yeah.
- Yeah, it's hard to do hard work.
You know, people have
egos, like, you know,
I tell the kids all the
time, at 27 years old
I was in a liquor store in
New Jersey ringing people up
and taking boxes to the car.
That's my life, I was doing that.
So of course when you're
24 and you're freaked out
that you haven't made it yet,
of course I'm gonna
laugh at that, of course.
I lived something else,
I want you to see it.
So I think it's communication.
- Do you think, 'cause obviously
your take is very objective
about work, entrepreneurship
and if people only keep scrolling
they don't see anything about
your being a father of two
or a husband, is it,
obviously it's by design?
- Of course.
I think I'm the most public,
I'm the most public
private person there is.
- Yes, you see, so there's
the others that will,
I don't want to say sabotage
but they will put out their
family and they become--
- Easy likes.
- Yeah.
- You know what gets easy likes,
girlfriends and boyfriends.
Your pet, children, lay up.
I am convinced that there
are enormous amounts
of people in the world that have children
just for Instagram.
- Like a bag, like a designer bag.
- Now, that doesn't bother
me, believe it or not,
because I believe an enormous
amount of people have children
because they think they're
supposed to at a certain age
because their mother's
putting pressure on them.
Like, there's a lot of other
reasons people, you know.
- Especially in this region.
- Of course, listen, one
of the one of the reasons
I think I do resonate quite a bit in Asia,
in the Middle East, in
other parts of the world,
is I deeply understand immigrant culture.
I deeply, and I understand
old-world culture.
- And they connect to you also.
- 100%, and old-world culture, you know,
like, so I get it, I get it.
I mean, the biggest one
in the region for me,
the single biggest reason I
love coming to this region
is just to go on stage and
put pressure on the parents
to stop using their children
as collateral for their own ego.
The number one flaw the one thing that,
Americans are detached
from their children,
which I don't think is great,
but the one thing that is
extreme in this part of the world
is parents tell kids to do things
that makes them look
good, not makes their,
it's 100% selfish.
This part the world, Asia, India,
wildly selfish parents
who force their kids
'cause it makes, you don't
wanna embarrass the family,
you have to go to that
school to make me look good,
you have to be an engineer or a banker
or you have to go to Harvard in America
to make me look good.
I haven't even paid attention
to what makes you happy,
you're a product of me.
And you know what makes me mad,
and I talked to some of these
63 year-olds, 45 year-olds,
I'm like, this one hurts me
about the cliche 22 year old kid
in this part of the world,
they listen to their parents
talk about how their
grandparents made them miserable
for doing what they wanted
and they're just repeating
the same behavior.
- It's human behavior also.
- Of course it is,
but it's time for it to stop.
And things stop when people start talking.
And the reason I'm saying this
right now is for that reason,
hopefully the next person takes it.
And it didn't start with me,
these things were things I heard
or observed or who the hell, you know,
sometimes you don't know
where you got it from
but it's happening and actually
a lot of what works for me,
and this might help others,
I think so much of who I've become
has to do with my
listening, not my talking.
I read comments, DMs,
emails, that's how I learned.
People tell me things.
- How is it being a father?
- It's really interesting being
a father, I'll explain why.
I am so in love with my children
yet I am so passionate to
not impose anything on them.
- You know, Will Smith spoke some
literally law of attraction shit,
so last week, recommended
video, click on it.
Will Smith talks about
how Willow, his daughter,
was the challenge of his life
because he wants to impose
things because we do that,
like you said to feed our
ego, to impose things on her
and he's like, I realized
that our kids are like seeds,
the seed would be what it would be,
whatever plant they may be.
Us as parents should just
give the environment.
- 100%.
My daughter is already showing
that she is a remarkable student.
She might be the best in class
in a private school in New York.
My daughter's much
better at school at this,
my daughter is a much
better reader right now
than I ever was.
And like, that makes me happy.
Like, when sometimes my
friends figure this out
they're like, are you okay?
I'm like, with what?
They're like, you hate school.
I'm like, I hate school for
me, I love school for her.
She's learning her ass off.
I don't have any absolutes,
I just want flexibility.
I don't have absolutes
even though I speak in absolute terms.
Everybody else has absolutes.
- Yeah, black or white.
- Right, I'm only gray.
I'm just talking about things
that are the alternative
to the accepted black.
Got it, that's what I doing.
- I think I operate in the same,
I don't think one size
fits all for anything.
- It can't, you know why, we're logical.
- Very, dangerously so sometimes.
Yeah, but by the way,
that's how we're, you know,
that's how we got to this.
It can't one-size-fits-all,
here's the proof.
Here's me not, and I can
show you a million people
that are happy, functional,
and wildly successful
that crushed school and
loved it and that's amazing.
But, you know what's
interesting, I grew up in the US
when entrepreneurship was
nothing and school was the.
And so now to see it the
reverse, that, it's funny,
that's why I'm pushing against
entrepreneurship for everyone.
- You want to read that balance.
- I just want self-awareness,
individual, individual,
him, him, him, him, her, her.
Individual, what makes you
happy, what are you good at?
And then more, you said
something very smart
and I added something but I
think we should go back to it.
If you love something
and you're good at it
it's going to be a big win.
I think the nuance on that
is if you love something
and you're not good at it
it might be worth doing
'cause being happy is more
important than making money
but you have to be honest with yourself
that you're only gonna make
$40,000 a year being a painter
'cause nobody's gonna buy your painting.
If you learn to live on
a $40,000 a year budget.
This is what, you know what's funny?
I realized something
about me, I'm like, right,
I'm cooking an entire meal
with the things I talk about.
So in individual ingredients
when people look at it
it might be one thing
but if you take all the things I'm saying
it's an entire meal.
Okay, and I like how you
wrapped it, I like that.
I like it too 'cause I think
it can bring a lot of happiness
and if you understand
how the internet works
there's a lot of people
that can be much happier
if they settle into, I'm a
$63,000 a year t-shirt maker.
You see where I'm going?
But it takes another ingredient
and I know this a good one
'cause I'm really getting them right now,
you have to live a life
on the means of $63,000.
you can't be a $63,000 a year t-shirt guy
but mommy and daddy are
giving you $100,000 a year
so that you can live in
a better neighborhood
and drive a BMW 'cause that's
gonna lead to resentment
between mom and dad and you
and entitlement from you.
If you want to be a
big-shot, I love when people,
you know, some of my more
young liberal friends are like,
I just want to be happy.
And I'm like, no, you want to just do art
but you want your parents to pay for it.
We need more real conversations.
We have to put making 63,000 a year
because you love t-shirts
and that's all you can do on
Shopify and at the flea market,
you have to buy a home
that you can afford,
you have to go to the Holiday
Inn, not the Ritz-Carlton.
If we can get to that it could get big,
it could get real big.
And the way we do that is
by us applauding our friends
who make 63,000 and go
Holiday Inn, not, (groans)
look, I went to the Ritz-Carlton.
- You know what's funny, I
got a comment, a guy told me,
I was in economy with my
kids and I took a picture
and I posted it on the
story and he goes honestly,
I don't get you.
I'm like, excuse me?
He goes, one day you're on a private jet,
the other day you're in first
class, now you're in economy.
I'm like, oh, so when I'm in economy
I'm not supposed to post,
that's what you're telling me?
I'm like, bro, it doesn't matter,
I'm with my family, I'm happy.
It doesn't change the fact that I have to,
oh, no, I have to run off to first class
because I've become, but that's the world.
- Not the world I live in.
- Neither me but I guess we're
the strangers at some point
which hopefully becomes the common.
- It's gonna become the common
'cause this is gonna break.
There's so much unhappiness in the world.
- Unsustainable.
- It's not sustainable.
- Okay, I'll go to different questions.
You seem, generally, people
can say that you're loud,
fast paced, like you're
running out of time,
maybe some people say you're angry,
do you feel these feelings,
do you feel you're running out of time,
that you need to do so much?
- No, I feel like I have so much time.
I'm definitely not angry.
People confuse how one communicates
in a certain environment
for their truth.
When I'm on stage talking to
5,000 people and I'm hyped,
and if I'm angry I'm angry at the systems
that have created their unhappiness.
I'm actually thrilled that I
escaped those vulnerabilities.
I'm actually so grateful it's funny.
So, yeah, I see all those
comments and Adderall,
the funniest one is my college friends
spent their entire four years
trying to get me to smoke weed
and I promised my mom in seventh grade
that I would never do drugs
so when people leave the
comment like Adderall or cocaine
because I'm so fast and
hyper my college friends
get the biggest kick 'cause
they just think it's so funny
'cause they're like
man, if they just knew.
I'm fast but that's just because
I have a lot of adrenaline
and I talk fast, like,
and my brain works fast.
- Do you think you have a big ego?
- No, I but I think I
have enormous confidence.
I think ego is insecurity.
- Yeah, if a big ego has a big insecurity.
I think we have all vulnerable egos
and it can be a good tool but
if you let it control you,
very dangerous.
- I actually have no
connection towards ego.
I don't think I'm special,
let's just start there.
I understand that I was gifted
things but that's not me.
I think my parents are special,
I think my parents should have an ego.
But I'm the byproduct.
How the hell, that's like,
I love people that are
gorgeous, they're funny to me.
You didn't do anything.
- Yeah you were born this way.
- And that how I feel.
Just 'cause I understand people
better than almost anybody I've
ever met, I didn't do that.
That's my parents had
sex at the right second.
It's hard, I mean this,
it's hard for me to
think I'm special or, you know.
- If somebody says, do you
like listening to yourself
and the wisdom that comes out of you?
- I consume nothing that I put out.
No, I do not lately sing to myself at all.
I like what I'm saying.
- What don't you like about Gary?
- That it took me a very long,
the thing I don't like about me
is the thing I'm most working on which is
on a one-to-one level
I struggle with candor
because I don't like
hurting people's feelings.
Which blows people away when I answer that
'cause I haven't shared that a
lot, I'm starting to share it
because I'm so raw and real on stage
but in real life for my
company and my relationships
I struggled with candor
because I hate negativity.
- Have you been depressed?
- No.
- The worst moment in your life?
- The worst moment in my life.
Probably when I realized
there was real conflict
between me and my dad,
when I kind of really knew,
there was one day when I left
this store, just left it,
which I never did, in November
when I was like 28, 29
and I knew, I knew that I
wouldn't be there anymore.
That was tough for me
because I really enjoyed
building that business for him
and I was willing to do it immigrant style
and be there for a very long time.
I'm so patient that I thought,
I can do this and build
this for him until I'm 50
and then I'll go build my own thing.
So that that hurt because there was more
that I wanted to give him.
- You cut the umbilical cord then.
- Yeah, that's just something
I've never really said,
I've never said this out loud, ever,
but it's the true answer.
It was tough because I felt bad for him.
- Like you let him down?
- No, that he let me get away.
- [Anas] Best moment in your life?
- When my daughter was born,
it's a very close one two,
it's either the day my book,
the second my daughter
was born I looked at her,
I was a side, she came out,
she was looking straight
and then she turned and looked at me.
I've never ever cried so
(snaps) on a second and so hard,
it was crazy.
- [Anas] Even I feel it.
- Yeah, it was, guys, it was super crazy.
I just am so grateful, it's so funny
how I have nothing close
to that with my son,
sorry Xander, but she came
out and I was right here
and when she turned I just,
it completely destroyed me
and that is either one or
it's two or it's tied with
the day that the New York
Jets beat the Patriots
in New England in the second
round of the playoffs in 2011.
I'm not kidding, the one place
that I'm completely irrational
because I'm not in control
is my deep love for the New York Jets.
The amount of pain the
Patriots have brought,
they had beaten the Jets 45
to three five weeks earlier,
it was the playoffs, all my friends
that usually come to Jet
games with me didn't go.
Just me and my brother
and two other people
'cause they didn't want to
go there and get slaughtered.
I walked in there like
I was gonna get killed,
like literally, like this is,
I'm not I'm gonna use the analogy
but I was walking into death.
I remember walking into that stadium,
everyone's making fun of us.
Not a word, no face, and to watch them
be able to beat them and see that
and then watch all those
Patriot fans have to leave
and this one guy was giving
me a really hard time
five rows in front of me, like
he was drunk, he was nasty.
You're gonna lose, like
spitting, almost fighting.
And then when it became obvious
the Jets we're gonna win
he tried to leave, I'll never forget this,
the Jets went up 10 points late,
the game was over and he tried to leave
and I was like six seats in off the aisle,
the most athletic thing
I've done in my life,
I somehow in one second went
over six people and grabbed him
and said, where the fuck
do you think you're going?
And it was like one of the
great moments of my life.
Maybe the best moment of my life.
- I like that.
- I love the journey, I love the journey.
- It makes you cherish the win.
- You know what's funny,
I will actually argue
that one of the great vulnerability,
one of things I don't like about Gary
is I'm incapable of smelling the roses.
I don't like the win.
I didn't like my birthday
the other, the team,
I had a really interesting
moment two weeks ago.
The team did something very sweet for me.
My team Gary made content
and put up my face
and a big thing for me in Times Square
and they brought me into
an office and were like,
we gotta show you something.
and DRock and DKirk were in
Times Square during the hour
and were live for me
to see it and I reacted
as if they like stole my wallet.
And a lot of the team
doesn't know me that well
and I remember thinking, this sucks
because this was so
sweet and I'm so grateful
but I'm incapable of faking my emotions.
So I just, I don't like,
- I know what you mean.
- You understand?
It's a vulnerability of mine.
- I think I'm never fully satisfied.
- You know what's funny,
I'm fully satisfied and,
I'm fully satisfied right now.
When I win I don't like it.
I don't like it, I just like the game.
It's why I think I'm
such a good entrepreneur.
I don't want the money,
I don't want the BMW.
- That was actually my next question
but I'm glad you telling me.
Continue, you don't want the BMW.
- No.
I mean, I'll drive a BMW,
it's fine, I don't have one.
But like, no, none of
this is for the stuff.
All of it is for, where do I rank
as the best entrepreneurs of all time?
Number 37, number 4 billion,
number 1, number 19,
like I'm playing the game, the real game.
And I think actually one of the reasons
that I think I've become
the entrepreneur that is
giving back by far the most
in my opinion to other
entrepreneurs with no.
- You're adding value for free.
- Is because I probably
subconsciously think
that's my hack to being
the best entrepreneur.
Because Bezos and some of these other,
they're putting up some real numbers
and I don't think I'm gonna get there
but in my own mind if I'm judging
entrepreneurship on impact
I genuinely think I'm having a huge impact
on the next generation of entrepreneurs
and that makes me proud and
wherever that means in ranking
it feels very good.
- Last few questions.
It's very close to what you just said,
we're born, Gary, with a need to feel seen
or valued or relevant, it's anything.
It's like a child saying,
daddy, look at me do this
or look at my--
- Yes, yes, yes, yes.
- What makes you feel seen and valued,
like you're adding value, what is it?
- The feedback of admiration.
I'm chasing admiration.
Everybody out here is
chasing private jets,
I'm chasing admiration.
It's one thing to be seen,
it's another thing to be seen for what.
Are you being seen
because you know how to kick
a football past a goalie?
Are you being seen because
you're wildly attractive?
Are you being seen because you're funny?
Are you being seen because you stole money
and it looks like you've made money?
Like, what are you being seen for?
I want to be seen more
than anybody in the world,
why I'm being seen is
what I'm most proud of.
- I like that.
To many you seem fearless,
but what are you afraid of?
- Snakes, don't like snakes so much.
- Yeah, me too, I don't like reptiles.
- Yeah, snakes are fucked up, you know.
I don't like snakes.
I fear the death of 10 or 11 people a lot.
I actually think the first
time I truly disappear
for a little while is probably
one of my parents death.
I can see myself really going into
a form of depression or a funk
because I lived my complete
life on the gratitude
that those people are healthy and happy.
I'm completely, the reason
I'm fearless and happy
is because it's about those 12 people.
So my fear intuition, it's
really the one thing left for me.
At 44 there's one thing left
that I'm curious about with me
which is when I lose one
of them what happens?
Do I do what I normally do
which is default into
such optimism that I say,
I'm so lucky that I had
all this time with them.
Or have I put all my chips in there.
and when one of them
goes I do go into a place
where I can't get my juices goin'
for a month, three months, a year.
I don't know that answer but
that is the one thing left
that I want to, that I'm excited,
I mean it, even though I fear it.
It's the one thing that
I'm, it's the last piece
of curiosity I have about me
because everything else is very obvious.
- Any regrets?
- You know what's funny,
I'm really good at not regretting things
but I will say this,
I do believe that I took it too far
when it comes to work
ethic between 14 and 30.
I worked every minute,
nobody will ever know.
My mom got emotional about
it a couple years ago,
she's like, they'll never believe you.
Because she almost feels bad, my dad too,
I mean, I worked every
minute, all of them.
I mean, all of them,
literally every weekend,
every summer vacation of my
entire adolescence I worked.
And I don't think that's
healthy, that's too much,
I could have used some balance.
So I do regret that a little bit, I do.
My problem is it's hard for me to regret
because I think me being so unique
has led to so much happiness that I,
I'm trying to challenge myself
to actually answer these
questions with that
but then I have to say
this for the record,
and then even as I just told you that
in my chemicals I can feel
like, no, I don't regret it
because the extremes that I went through
created a very unique voice
that leads to all my happiness.
I can't, I can't.
- It's your journey.
- It's my journey, I can't, I'm too happy.
I'm just deeply happy and
grateful, I can't critique.
- Last one, Gary in one word?
- That's really good, Gary in one word.
Kind.
- I like that, thanks man.